hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to will you press them
button now is heavily requested that I
play the skin again and I'm more than
happy to do so because it creates a lot
of very interesting ethical dilemmas
where I end up blowing up Detroit for
cake and forgetting a lot of very
important quotes so you will go into the
world of your favorite series but you
will not be able to interact with your
favorite character now what is my
favorite series oh this opens up a lot
of really interesting questions because
do I want to go into a world where
everything is fantastic but the series
is actually really dark and horrible or
do I want to go into a fantastic series
like Hogwarts or maybe I want to go into
a mundane series like the office and
then interact with my favorite
characters there or not interact with my
favorite characters oh I don't know I
think if I had to really choose based on
the universe that I could go into I
would choose the Fullmetal Alchemist
universe because the idea that alchemy
could actually be real in a science and
something that you learn and gain
knowledge from and even though I
wouldn't be able to interact with El
Edward Elric it's ok because then I'd
get to meet everyone else in the world
and hopefully play an important part
even though the world is kind of dark it
would still be cool I would totally be
down for that good very good
you will become a highly successful
well-paid musician but you hate the
sound of your own music more than any
other and must tour on a regular basis
oh God
well that's kind of the idea that you
would be successful in something you
don't like so you wouldn't be satisfied
in what you're doing because even if you
were a musician but if you didn't like
your own music that you were making it
would kinda be so soul sucking that you
wouldn't even want to do it I don't know
would you guys actually want to do that
because I will not press that button oh
no way oh my god I'll be kissed on the
nearest possible Friday that's today ok
sorry you ride a motorcycle that never
crashes but you can never ride in
anything else with wheels or airplanes
oh well that's the case that's totally
fine
give me my motorcycle it'll never crash
I'll strap literally like I'll call NASA
they'll put Rockets on my motorcycle
and I'll just zip at 6000 miles per hour
wherever I want to go and never crash
that would be amazing of course I'm
gonna press that button that's awesome
65% did not Oh grow some balls you will
be able to do anything you want for the
rest of your life but you have to hide
your identity I mean that sounds pretty
good to me you get to do whatever you
want then you never have to be
accountable for it you could be a
horrible horrible is this like saying
you can literally do anything you want
like you could manipulate the universe
into doing anything or you can literally
just kind of say like oh my god be free
but no one will ever remember you
because I don't know if it's the first
then I'm okay with that I would press
the button but then I'd have to hide my
identity but that doesn't mean that
people would know me I just have to come
up with a fake I press that button that
sounds good yeah of course who wouldn't
constantly while you were asleep you
were able to control dreams you were
able to create your own imaginary world
and do whatever you want but you need 28
hours of sleep per day and you were only
able to be awake for four hours hey if I
could be asleep for 20 hours a day that
would be my dream I would be so happy I
would be so happy if I got to sleep that
long and who then I actually stayed
asleep and then when I'm asleep it's
like when I'm awake will be my dream
world whatever oh man that would be
really sad because then I wouldn't
actually be in reality but I'd have a
controllable door oh man
oh that's a dilemma I think I'd press
that button I think I'd present I'd do
that that would be really all that split
right down the middle for that one oh
it's so good you can go into or out of
any video games you want but you can't
play any sort of multiplayer while
inside the game totally fine with me
I am a hundred percent not letting other
people ruin my game experience with
their douchiness it's my game I'm going
into it the way I want to go into it and
no one's gonna ruin it for me so there
you go I'm pressing the button exactly
who wouldn't
that button it's you have access to
anything you want in the world but you
have to share everything with 10 7 year
olds that sounds like the situation I
have with my nieces and nephews right
now there's about 10 of them I think and
they're all about 12 years and younger
and every time I come over they all want
to play with me and then wreck my day
and ruin my life but I have access to
everything oh god what if they get hold
than the nuclear arsenals that business
sound is good oh my god for the
responsibility of the world it will not
press that button you can tell when
someone is lying to you but you can't
call them out on it ok that's fine I'll
just manipulate everything behind their
back so that I know exactly what's going
on and how to use that to my advantage
actually that does seem like something
that you could do if you don't need to
call them out on it then maybe it's
better because they don't know that you
know that are lying but then you can
work around that to your advantage oh
yeah oh definitely press that button so
what a lot of people you are super cute
super talented and super great in bed
but you're socially awkward that's my
life right now it's true maybe I don't
know ok I'll press it once again you
guys get to know a lot about me a lot
you get to work at a stable well-paying
job for the rest of your life but the
work conditions are terrible the boss is
horrible the hours are unreasonable and
the job itself is incredibly dumb dull
know who would press that would blows a
terrible one that's so stupid
have all food replaced with candy but
this includes toothpaste so your teeth
would rot away you know if all food was
replaced by candy you would get so sick
so soon because oh you your body can't
handle pure sugar like the only reason
you're able to tolerate pure sugar in
like sodas is because it's cut with
other chemicals that's why if you eat a
bunch of candy you'll get sick
I will not bad you can download every
visual thought to your computer
oh this concludes dreams imaginations
and drunken experiences that you may
have forgotten but life as you know it
is now in black and white though you and
others can view the recordings in color
yes that would be so cool if I could
actually put what's in my mind onto my
computer I could create such amazing
visual tapestries and that's not even
exaggerating sailing or in my mind it's
such a unique and interesting experience
I have such an artist in my mind I just
can't read no I'm not saying that at all
I'm saying everyone has the ability to
create wild and vivid things in their
mind the brain is an incredible organ
and can do amazing things that would be
so good I'm really 42% of people
wouldn't tolerate the world in black and
white just to be able to do that you
could create so much so many cool things
so much porn you conquer your fear of
spiders but to do so you have to sleep
in a bed with thousands of them for one
all night I'm not afraid of spiders but
I think anybody would be afraid of
spiders after sleeping in a bed with
them thousands of them for one night
what do you have to do with them in bed
I will not no way god no yeah you have
the ability to become a cat whenever you
want but once you do it it's permanent
that doesn't seem good at why would I
want to be a cat I am perfectly fine
being a human thank you
you can have any superhero power but
first you have to use it on a bus filled
with senior citizens Oh what if my power
is like to heal and he wound then I'd
have to use it on them but if I actually
want an important powers then they
wouldn't do well I guess that would be a
very important power you can heal
anybody but that's not what I choose
maybe there's like an over encompassing
power that I could do that where if I
have to use it on a bus filled with
seniors it's what if I was able to
manipulate make as I wanted any part of
the human body and I could make them all
young again and healthy and then I could
carry on that power and then that also
could be used to fight evil because if
some big baddies come by me um you're
not small
not small but littler and then they
punch him and I punch every old person
on that bus I punch him and punch him
and then I push the babies too and then
I make the babies into old people no
people than the babies and then I punch
each other and then I keep punching them
in the face and gonads and I switch
their gonads with their face I punch
bulls at once
I shouldn't be given any power ever
Alfred president I'll press that button
who wouldn't press that button
vegetables tastes like bacon but bacon
tastes like boiled eggplant
wait isn't that like you catch-22
because I love vegetables and if they
taste like bacon hey even awesomer but
then I just I wouldn't eat bacon there's
nothing to this of course
oh no Pokemon is in real life including
all logic technology and pokemons but
all animals in real life will be gone
forever so literally pokemons would
become real and then replace every
animal in society okay since you guys
are the ones that actually like Pokemon
because I don't hate Pokemon it's just
like I feel like the games are
repetitive a bit but I mean it's not
like I a bore Pokemon
I watched Pokemon as a kid so I'll leave
this one up to you what do you have
Pokemon be real in all of its wonder
glory [ __ ] or whatever it may or may
not be but every animal that's currently
exists in existence and that includes
dogs and cats and ferrets and bunnies
and all the cute adorable animals that
you love would be gone and replaced with
Pokemon would you do that I'll leave
that up to you so thank you everybody so
much for watching I really enjoy playing
this game sorry even really a game I
really enjoyed doing this and I hope you
enjoyed to let me know how you think in
the comments below please answer my
question in the comments as well I will
be reading through them and seeing your
wondrous interesting answers so thank
you again everybody and as always I will
see you in the next video
I feel like this would lead to a lot
more problems than just was seen on the
surface so really now I look like an
[ __ ]